es uno de los hombres más poderosos de
corea del sur y como muchos magnates que
le han precedido lee jae yong recibió el
indulto del presidente de corea del sur
respondiendo a la medida al que había
sido condenado por corrupción el año
pasado prometió que haría que el indulto
valiera la pena para el país
trabajaré duro por la economía nacional
al y se le concedió el indulto de la
última sentencia que se le impuso en
enero de 2021 se suponía que debía
cumplir dos años y medio en prisión pero
fue puesto en libertad condicional en
agosto de ese mismo año el escándalo de
sobornos y malversación de fondos
derrocó al expresident aparquen en 2017
lee jae yong que ahora puede volver a
tomar plenamente las riendas de samsung
no es el único al que se le ha concedido
el perdón otros tres gigantes
empresariales también fueron indultados
este viernes incluyendo el presidente
del grupo loc según dice que la medida
es de interés económico para corea del
sur ante la urgente necesidad de superar
la crisis económica nacional hemos
seleccionado cuidadosamente a los
líderes económicos que serán indultados
porque pueden impulsar el crecimiento a
través de la inversión tecnológica y la
creación de empleo al darles la
oportunidad de participar en este
desarrollo una vez más pretendemos
maximizar nuestros esfuerzos para
superar la crisis económica
los indultos vuelven a suscitar el
debate sobre el trato preferente en
corea del sur a las élites empresariales
y a la clase política la expresidenta
par bunge también fue indultada en
diciembre